DIDN’T HAVE TO TAKE THEM.
ALL YOU NEEDED TO DO IS ASK.
I’M SURE THE ANSWER WOULD HAVE
BEEN YES IN FLORIDA,
GOVERNOR RON DeSANTIS TOOK A
VERY STEPS RIGHT AWAY TO SHIELD
FLORIDA’S VERY HIGH PERCENTAGE
OF RETIREMENT COMMUNITIES IN
NURSING HOMES FROM THE VIRUS
INCLUDING THE VILLAGES,
AMERICA’S FRIENDLIEST HOMETOWN
THAT INCLUDED TARGETED TESTING,
DISTRIBUTION, STRICT ISOLATION
AT RISK COMMUNITIES AND THE
RESULTS BE FOR THEMSELVES.
THEY FATALITY RATE AT LONG-TERM
NURSING CARE FACILITIES WAS
DRASTICALLY LOWER THAN NEW YORK.
WAS 1.2%.
NEW YORK, 18%.
NOW THE STATE HAS A PLAN TO
SAFELY REOPEN FOR BUSINESS AND
LET FLORIDIANS GET BACK ON THEIR
FEET.
HERE WITH MORE, FLORIDA
GOVERNOR RON DeSANTIS.
WAS VERY INTERESTING BECAUSE I
WAS WATCHING THE MEDIA COVERAGE
AND YOU ADDRESS THIS IN D.C.
TODAY.
I WAS WATCHING.
THE PREDICTIONS FOR FLORIDA
WHICH DIDN’T SURPRISE ME BECAUSE
OF THE HIGH PERCENTAGE OF YOUR
POPULATION BEING THE ELDERLY
WERE OFF THE CHARTS.
THEY ATTACKED YOU EVERY STEP OF
THE WAY.
YOU WANTED TO KEEP BEACHES OPEN
WITH SOCIAL DISTANCING BECAUSE
HAVE PEOPLE OUT, FRESH AIR, LIFT
THEIR SPIRITS.
LOOK AT YOUR NUMBER ON THAT
GRAPH RIGHT THERE AND LOOK AT
NEW YORK.
OF THE THIRD ONE IN HIS
MICHIGAN.
MICHIGAN YOU CAN ARGUE DOESN’T
HAVE THE DENSE POPULATION OF
NEW YORK.
HOW DID YOU DO IT BECAUSE WE
NEED TO LEARN AS WE REOPEN.
>> WE REALLY FOCUSED BECAUSE WE
KNEW WHERE THE THREAT WAS AND WE
KNEW WHERE THE VULNERABILITIES
WERE WHEN YOU’RE TALKING ABOUT
PUTTING OUT 7 MILLION MASTS AND
GLOVES AND FACE SHIELDS, MAKING
SURE WE HAVE TEAMS GOING THERE
TO TRY TO SEE WHERE THE
INFECTIONS ARE COMING FROM, TRY
TO WORK ON KEEPING THOSE AT BAY
SENDING NATIONAL GUARD UNITS
INTRODUCED BOUGHT TESTING IN
THOSE FACILITIES, THAT IS ALL
RECOGNITION THAT IF THE VIRUS
GETS INTO THOSE FACILITIES, IT
CAN RUN RAMPANT, SO WE WORKED
REALLY HARD TO DO THAT.
I GOT A GREAT SECRETARY FOR
HEALTH CARE ADMINISTRATION WHICH
HAS REALLY SPEARHEADED.
SHE WAS FIGHTING THE WHOLE TIME.
SHE WOULDN’T LET A HOSPITAL PUT
A SICK COVID PATIENT BACK IN A
NURSING HOME.
SHE SAID YOU GUYS HAVE TO KEEP
THESE FOLKS BECAUSE THEY WILL
INFECT THE REST OF THE NURSING
HOME SO IT’S A VERY DIFFICULT
PROBLEM BUT BECAUSE WE WERE
PROACTIVE, WE’VE HAD MUCH BETTER
RESULTS ON A MUCH LOWER DEATH
RATE THAN WE OTHERWISE WOULD.
>> Sean: I HAD THE HEAD ON MY
RADIO SHOW COME ABOUT 16,000
CORONAVIRUS PEOPLE CONTRACTED
IT, VERY LOW DEATH RATE, NOBODY
IN THE MILITARY, NOT ONE DEATH.
THEY TRACK PEOPLE IN TERMS OF
THEIR LOCATION WITH THEIR PHONE,
INTENSIVE CONTACT TRACING,
GOVERNMENT INVOLVEMENT.
MIGHT BE CIVIL LIBERTIES AND
CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUES, BUT IT
WORKED AND I WANT TO LOOK AT
EVERY PLACE LIKE WHERE THINGS
WORKED DRAMATICALLY BETTER AS WE
NOW REOPEN THE COUNTRY.
NEW YORK HAS SPECIAL CHALLENGES,
I THINK 50% OF THE WORKPLACE CAN
WORK FROM HOME, I THINK YOU
COULD PUT PEOPLE IN RESPIRATORS
WHO WORE MASKS AND GLOVES IN THE
WORKPLACE, YOU HAVE SOCIAL
DISTANCING AS YOU OPEN AND I
THINK STADIUMS CAN OPEN.
ARE YOU THINKING ABOUT OPENING
UP FOR MLB, NFL, MAYBE EVEN NBA?
>> CERTAINLY WE WANT TO GET
THERE.
I’M NOT GOING TO PROMISE THAT AT
THE OUTSET TOMORROW BUT HERE’S
THE THING, WE KNOW WHO THE
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS ARE.
YOU LOOK AT THE STATISTICS FOR
PEOPLE UNDER 50 WHO DON’T HAVE
CHRONIC CONDITIONS, YOU HAVE AN
EXTREMELY LOW CHANCE OF DEATH
FROM THIS VIRUS IN THOSE
SITUATIONS AND WE KNOW HOW TO
PROTECT FOLKS AND SOCIAL
DISTANCE BETWEEN THOSE TWO
GROUPS SO I THINK THERE’S A LOT
OF THINGS WE’VE LEARNED OVER THE
LAST SIX WEEKS SO I THINK WE CAN
TAKE A STEP FORWARD HERE IN MAY
AND CONTINUE TO BUILD ON THAT
AND GET AMERICA BACK.
I WAS THINKING THINGS IN LIFE
THAT WE TAKE FOR GRANTED, I’VE
BEEN WORKING AS GOVERNOR EVERY
DAY BUT JUST THINK OF ALL THE
PARENTS WHOSE KIDS AREN’T IN
SCHOOL, LITTLE LEAGUE IS NOT
GOING ON.
THEY DON’T HAVE ALL THESE THINGS
THAT WE’VE TAKEN FOR GRANTED.
I THINK PEOPLE WANT SOME HOPE
AND SOME OPTIMISM AND I THINK WE
ARE AT THE PLACE WHERE THIS HAS
BEEN TOUGH BUT WE HAVE A CHANCE
TO GET TO THE LIGHT AT THE END
OF THE TUNNEL SO THAT’S WHAT WE
ARE TRYING TO DO IN FLORIDA OVER
THE NEXT MANY WEEKS.
>> Sean: I’LL GO THROUGH A
TEMPERATURE CHECK.
I’LL WEAR A MASK IF I CAN GO TO
A BASEBALL GAME.
I’LL DO WHATEVER IT TAKES TO
PROTECT EVERYBODY ELSE.
HOW MUCH LONGER ARE YOU GOING TO
KEEP ME OUT OF YOUR STATE?
I WOULD LIKE TO GO VISIT.
FLORIDA IS MY SECOND HOME.
WHEN AM I ALLOWED BACK IN?
>> YOU CAN COME, BUT WE ARE
GOING TO SELF ISOLATE YOU FOR 14
DAYS.
>> Sean: WHEN DOES THAT END?
>> IF YOU AGREE TO MOVE YOUR
SHOW TO NAPLES, I WILL DO AN
ABBOTT LABS TEST FOR YOU, LET
YOU RUN LOOSE AND WE’LL LET YOU
BROADCAST FROM NAPLES.
>> Sean: I WILL GET TESTED, I
WILL MAKE SURE I’M SAFE.
MORE IMPORTANTLY, WILL THERE BE
AN OPENING FOR PEOPLE OUTSIDE OF
FLORIDA TO GET BACK IN WITHOUT
THE 14 DAYS SOONER?
>> WE’RE GOING TO WORK ON THAT.
NEW YORK IS A SPECIAL CASE.
WE DON’T WANT TO SEE ANY MORE
INFECTIONS BUT WE ARE GOING TO
WORK ON IT.
YOU DID A GREAT JOB, SAVED A LOT
OF LIVES AND THERE’S A LOT TO
LEARN FROM YOUR SUCCESS.